[Music]
three two one action welcome back to
author we talk about whatever we it was
so good that he got horny that's pretty
good Wow you've never done the show I've
never been on this I can't believe that
cuz you've been around forever forever
yeah this is crazy I don't we've been
friends for like what like 10 10 years
yeah I went to college together film
school together homeschool to get a life
you know why cuz a university I met Wes
when he was always behind the scenes
like a director and all that it was
until recently I say recently because of
how long I've known you but you do now
in front of the camera you're acting
you're actually like doing more stuff
like as a as a persona yeah so I've
always had this like mentality of like
your director and like maybe a filmmaker
and then like sometimes you'll do like
acting for fun yeah that's the other way
around a lot of people know you as like
doing comedy on Instagram and stuff yeah
what is the kind of guy like like when
we were in film school and we were doing
projects and stuff really we're doing
music videos and you'll be directing I'm
like you do all the [ __ ] better than the
actual talent in front of the camera do
you actually direct them and yes perform
it way better than anyone you've ever
worked through this guy [ __ ] die why
does everyone talk about he made us
laugh so much and now he's known I'm
missing like Mel Gibson but can actually
direct yeah not because Cate when Casey
knew me I was more so like directing and
trying to pursue like music videos but
then we'd be around each other and like
we wouldn't have any other actors to do
stuff so we just do it ourselves hustle
hard no no you know what like I was
really inspired by you guys that's a low
bar to [ __ ] go for bro yeah I love
that tell me more
the B this is a big bromance watching
you guys like back in the day I was like
how the [ __ ] are you doing this like it
was like it was blonde before Casey
because before Casey was a really boule
yeah because Casey made the magic happen
you know I'm saying like I see the
secret sauce videos bow like I've never
seen him I've never seen anyone where
you got to show you an anniversary video
you found them through Casey right yeah
I guess he was my roommate well I was
Casey's roommate actually I was sleeping
on Casey's couch so I guess we were yeah
so you guys met in college man in
college Casey skiing on chicks and stuff
no can we go back to there might be
mesmerized by JK no it is so crazy dude
this is a perfect time to think Casey
because I kind of cut your kid you like
now it's my funeral right thank you
thank you you know I I came out here
because my neighbor was like I'm moving
to LA on Monday and I was like who do I
know in LA I was like you know Casey he
knows crazy I'm about to come out to LA
and I have a meeting on Wednesday you
think I say your house for like a day or
two think yeah come to and that turned
into like six months what Casey is like
the perfect person to take advantage of
because no this how nice this dude is
like if if I needed to like couch-surf
on his place for 20 years I'd be able to
do it Wow if you were single it's a
rough town man especially you're like
because I was going I was only out here
for a year maybe when you gave me the
calls are you that first year in LA it's
rough man like I'm like I was just like
I cannot believe I'm here
like in Tujunga sleeping tonight it was
like yeah like it's a take bro
yeah we could we were on that please
couldn't afford a place in Central LA we
had to like go out into the boonies of
Tujunga which is like like 20 30 minutes
north of Glendale I had no idea and I
still have no I
it's in the Bernie do you new Casey
before you go - yeah so okay so one of
the guys who back then you're like hey
man that's gonna be crazy
she's already got a kid no I'm trying to
find that person I was I was always like
supported I think the one before was
like what's going on friend was like a
responsible human being compared to the
person the previous year was the reason
why you had to get you got the boot
because of her oh I was there for quite
some time it was it was there was a
cross roads were like just I've what was
a Hello Kitty just started investigating
microwave tell you to leave or did he is
one of those Casey talks like hey man
you know you know if the [ __ ] speaks
yeah there's only room for one
freeloader here she was a freeloader -
wait reloader that can be here nobody
else yeah she was that she was she was
little she was in that case was she hot
enough to be worth it no
that's enough the thing was it was like
you had a good setup and then you went
completely left I was about to go right
me so you know another girl he dated now
it was it was there was names like
parallel parallel it was like it was two
things going on to save time I met two
girls at this relatively same time but
then let's just say that the hellokitty
one kind of took its course first and
the other one came in maybe a few weeks
right afterwards but then since things
were going so fast as the heli kid you
want she's like oh [ __ ] that one's so
much better you couldn't pull the brakes
on the Hello Kitty rough-road even the
whole time I'm like what do you see in
our case yeah is that right
well I man that Casey what they've been
together for like a year already so I
couldn't I didn't yeah but in my mind
I'm like yeah
what yeah thank Y but I liked her around
cuz she would punch Casey's balls like
actually punch what he's building the
abusive yeah middle of filming and he's
punching up and we're waiting for kids
to give us direction
he's just getting punched in the nuts
like constantly in between tips you just
walk off in your honor he's not serving
carrot cake yeah yeah he's like filming
us and she'd be like nut check oh like
it's all good so Joel Jacob it's have
like a bunch of that and it's hard to
hit on her because she's like holding
the bounce board right this is helping
she goes BAM and you're like what the
[ __ ] she's can't help him but hurting
that's true cuz she would always be help
it always yeah I'd punch a nut and punch
it was that the trade-off she's like
I'll help you only if I get to punch you
in the nose yeah is she ever explain
herself you know what she's like I don't
want to just figuratively bust your
balls
I mean obsession with Hello Kitty
obsession with certain just personality
I mean it kind of speaks for itself I
just never had the shrink to say no
until maybe two years later perfect
Japanese persona what a nice guy Jesus
was she Mexican there she looked Amorim
she looks more Mexican and tifton's yeah
weights it's night she's she's Persian
typical Asian to us I thought she had
some Asian I remember you thinking she
was like Persian though yeah I remember
we had a conversation but she's Mexican
I thought she was Persian or Armenian
the first time I met Mexican a
middle-eastern
could kind of pass yeah you know like
you're in there I get it depends on the
style like the fashion you could do it
you know you could pull some people yeah
I mean there was this episode of South
Park when they got a bunch of Mexican
guys from Home Depot and then they gave
um not gold chains and a silky shirt so
yeah that's uh it's kind of like the
history I mean Casey well welcome to JK
man I know dude that's crazy
when did you convert from like the more
director role to like the more on camera
personality vine oh that's right because
you're friends with like storm and now
like I well I was I was directing over
it being a Mari they do like
Kardashian's of real world but I was
doing like their YouTube stuff so we
were producing like two pieces of
content like every day and at the same
time vine came out so I started filming
the Viners vines I was like oh yeah this
is cool but like I'm still trying to
direct television of stuff and a month
later everyone was getting like a
million followers and I was like
trick-or-treated maybe I should try and
do this you ever go to the vine
apartment yeah I was there out of the
time what huge one
the one you sleep on that couch as well
no 69 yeah dude yeah that [ __ ] was
[ __ ] hilarious I went there one time
because I had a meeting with a guy there
who's gonna be in this movie that we
were doing and we know that the name of
that guy dude the name is are you
purpose I will leave him leave him
aimless alright he doesn't need to be a
victim here so cuz I know nothing about
it too when I showed up I was like he
calls me and I'm like where I'm like
where are you and he's like I'm right
behind you and like from out of nowhere
comes this [ __ ] you know those little
scooters were you just standing up those
that's where I'd [ __ ] pictured coming
right at me with a parrot with no
handles no parrot no handles kid soon
because those biker guys are weird
no that's good I go up to the apartment
to the to the floor where all these vine
kids are on everyone's going around in
hoverboards and [ __ ] I'm not even
kidding and then I go into his apartment
and he's like opens this double door
fridge and he's like you want any you
want to get water he's like yeah this
sentence of me mmm it's like yeah like
[ __ ] he gets brain deals and [ __ ]
yeah no I think you know 1600 vine and I
lived off if a vine land in North
Hollywood like both those streets were
pretty much a circus for a good two
years and uh you know did you save their
money they did not say no I think I
think what they a lot of people didn't
do is they didn't really nurture their
content on other platforms they invested
it all into mind so you'd have 14
million followers and then the app
crashes and you have nothing only some
of them was able to transfer to YouTube
builds a lot of them that didn't though
and I think that just kind of that says
a lot about certain people and just kind
of like really you know if they're
looking at this like long-term where
this is just for like the moment some of
them wanted it to be long-term but the
business end of things I think is really
where people like [ __ ] up you know
especially that so that fall-off for
that drop office
it's huge big ways well cuz they're not
business people really yeah they're
making 30-second yeah you're 6 seconds 6
seconds yeah that's true because we all
got into YouTube like later in life like
we were 23 when we made her first JK
video this is like 12 years in the game
right so we were older than some of our
peers that came into YouTube and I think
just being younger you don't really have
that business and some people just got
it right but if they didn't have help
from their parents or family member like
I would see them squander the money or
they just kind of disappear after a
while but yeah I think just coming in a
little bit older and having friends and
people that's been through [ __ ] really
helped us out big time yeah it's all
about that balance man
and you got to be around people who who
kind of know a little bit about
something business because dude I
watched a very popular youtuber walk in
to maker studios back in the day and he
walks in crying and he's like and where
I'm going like oh my god like did your
pants die what happened holy [ __ ] like
were you just in the cartoon or
something he's like it was real like he
did I wish I could cry about pay 1.3
million dollars at taxes right god Dale
wasn't do it but if he spent all
probably tax no didn't know back then I
think he was 19 so he has no idea so he
blew all his money and then he Oded it
he wasn't making any more money
not as much not enough commits to pay
the tax pay on time so penalties were
steeper past his peak and he wasn't well
no he wasn't quite past his peak he was
still making [ __ ] but he didn't have
enough revenue to cover so you gotta
keep receipts for everything yeah you
know our returning [ __ ]
well and they don't buy a good
accountants and they don't buy anything
so they're like I don't have any write
downs or any markdowns we're all the
money go where they go right off just
[ __ ] around
I bet you strippers is kind of yeah they
could write that off later tame it but I
don't think that they were punks billing
the right cards don't think they set up
businesses like that kind of [ __ ]
keeping the paper you're thinking of it
from a level that he doesn't even
understand he's like well base level
he's used his business card right and
then he's like I mean you don't have an
LLC that kind of [ __ ] just went to the
ATM and withdrew it yeah that's it came
free you know as a kid man there's a lot
of kids they just love but I think one
16 year-olds one like what 3 million
dollars off of fortnight god damn yeah
they just had like the international
competition you want three mil
see that a part of me just out of
jealousy what's the problem when they no
I mean like when they blow it off just
like [ __ ] yeah oh yeah cuz I wish I was
16 and I had three million dollars and I
and I [ __ ] it up and then like let's
just train in Street Fighter we can do
it bro bro street fight will be a cop
will be like and how much money can you
make from a street fighter game I don't
know
I don't think it's 3 million but maybe
like 300,000 I'd be happy with that
it's nice that these games surviving
these like tech in Street Fighter
they're surviving past like the Rose
Street Fighter yeah yeah yeah Smash
Brothers dude Madden has won every year
too yeah yeah they have this big
competition called Evo where people go
and they end up winning money and it's
crazy I'm like Heike salty I don't even
want to hide it because I love talking
about how jealous I am that the younger
generation so like when we first started
YouTube the partner program wasn't even
bare we had to be invited right so like
since we kind of setup the taste for
everything like we don't get paid for it
though the younger generation do they're
the ones making like 30 million is [ __ ]
I mean I have every opportunity to do so
I just don't want to like record anybody
that committed suicide on video and
stuff that's not my style you know but
[Laughter]
I'm just salty goddamn I want to make 30
million a year but I can't do you really
though fill your house with bubbles then
if you prove it then see there's the
formula no you did you the prank we know
people that do it let me ask you guys a
question because this is very much your
space do you feel like these people who
are doing these types of videos are they
actually improving their craft or
getting better at what they do
so is there longevity in that like I
come from a very traditional training
background so like this is all brand new
and people like you don't do something
I'm like I just I don't know what I
think it's a different class so like I
didn't tradition where you're looking at
it as like like filmmaking it's a very
like artisan creative - yeah yeah I
think when you're more of like a
quote-unquote influencer the craft that
they've been able to hone is the
understanding the psychology of people
who watch them and understand understand
the consumer behavior yes so they don't
even need like to be a good actor or
good editor or good anything they just
know almost like they know the words to
say to create certain push certain
buttons yeah them to do things and then
the it's very primal
the views are explode and they sell
merch to back that up so yeah this big
business check an indie filmmaker okay
yes you
you drag a camera through a crop field
and that's nice but these cats are like
hey I got 30 million people to watch my
thing yeah I mean yeah of course there's
a value to that there's a difference
between like a being a influencer and
being influential you know I mean like
you have to like decide which which
route you're gonna go like if you're
gonna be influential you're gonna affect
people but you're not you're not doing
like being an influence or like there's
a certain gimmick that comes along with
with that title I personally don't like
the term influencer because you're
packed into this you're packed into this
like I grew up of weirdos is that too
but it's also like your press you know
me I don't want to be considered press
you're like hey come here and hey I
remember I went to I went to Paramount
how long ago and went to go see Gemini
man and see Will Smith and stuff like
that and that was like tight we went to
see like no I just went to see like the
director talk all right angry yeah oh
[ __ ] it was sick Will Smith was there
brought cameras there and we got to see
the technology that they did behind
promoting this film what I didn't like
was we're going to meet will and they're
like okay all right now it's time for
the influencers to get press photos and
I was like what the [ __ ] I'm here as you
know like someone that wants to create
features you want to be known as an
artist when you're meeting Will Smith
not as a part of the paparazzi but yeah
that's not what I hear yeah that's what
I was asking because you you know it's
like a fine line of here I'm gonna do a
10 second video which a hundred million
people are gonna watch or I'm gonna do a
two-hour movie and getting those same
people who are giving those views yes
come over and watch your stuff will they
do it that's why I wish the people that
filled their houses with bouncy balls
and [ __ ] I wish that they would have
little convent little little conventions
where you you screen it with a bunch of
kids and then you wear a [ __ ] toe
red carpet right and you're like you're
like you know and I when I when I filled
my house with bathwater did you do your
talkback right what's about how
society's drowning and how all my fans
will watch anything that I did see ya
and then all the kids are just like you
what the [ __ ] everyone take a picture
with you and go like that's all they
care about there's definitely a art
behind it but it's yeah it's the
difference between marketing and artists
like in like a creative person who's
inventing something yeah yeah yeah when
I go back to the schools because I show
this the last time I used to teach Zumba
and so I used to do a lot of
after-school programs so after I kind of
was acting and stuff and they saw me and
stuff they I'd come back to just see the
kids in all stuff and the first thing
they'd ask me is do you know this
youtuber do you know this youtuber they
never asked me about movie stars or TV
stars
it was always youtubers right and I was
like this is [ __ ] weird because then
you start asking them what do you want
to do what are you interested I want to
be a youtuber and to me that was the
equivalent of when I was growing up is
just I want to be famous
yes skill I don't know what they want to
be famous for exactly I went to go speak
back at our College are you doing yeah I
went to speak there and the filmmakers
there they wanted to be influencers they
want to create content yeah maybe
because they know the leverage from
having their own audience well everyone
I mean there's a balance between what
you love doing and you know surviving
and that's part of it right an artistic
world it's different well I mean put it
this way right like when we were the
title YouTuber was embarrassing when we
were coming up because all of us wanted
to do something else we just didn't have
an option it was only thing stones right
yeah I used YouTube as a way to create
like Asian American comedy or some [ __ ]
like that
because I can't I don't have a platform
at all on whatever channel so like
singers everything dancers they used
YouTube to get noticed so then they can
get into mainstream right absolutely but
then the kids who are following us
they're now older and they're the ones
looking up at us like I want to be a
youtuber and then they see them becoming
sick they're like [ __ ] being a star why
would you want to do that you control
your own empire if you're if you have
your own child I think it's dope
you know like that trend was set though
you know I mean I think this is you know
this Lane that we've created is is dope
because the brands and the companies
they're like how can we do that or how
can we be a part of it which is which is
really just shifted the way the business
is going hey dude biggest stars in the
world right now porn stars right you
don't exactly get to be celebrated for
that are the influencers the most watch
people on earth oh and they monetize to
[ __ ] out their videos really yeah I was
like yeah that's crazy they're making
their and they sell their [ __ ] [ __ ]
motors they have a skill that they say
we're gone yeah a skill a few more to go
there's definitely been some cinematic
growth as well yeah if you're [ __ ]
someone that you don't want to [ __ ] but
then you make it look dope that's a
skill enough but you're not really ever
tighten up on the storylines
I agree can I just skip tonight remember
I want to know why she's [ __ ] that
roomful of men
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]